socialism has many failures
so does capitalism and therefore we need
to
find a better way
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kitten and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is a left-wing
firebrand an mp
for two different parties one of which
he was a leader and most important man
united fan george gallagher welcome to
trigonometry thank you it's a pleasure
to be a big fan of your work really
and you're a broadcaster which i forgot
to add yeah you were on my show
very kind very popular segment actually
was it
yeah yeah very popular well i we're both
surprised about that but
uh thank you for having me and actually
one of the things that we wanted to talk
to you about is something you and i very
much talked about at the time which was
uh this and you and i had a lot of
agreement but this maybe was an era
where we were trying to work out what
each other was saying
which is i was talking about cancel
culture and you yourself have been
attacked
physically when speaking on university
campus by trans activist and we were
sort of trying to find common language
about
what seems to have happened on what i
perceive as the left
this seems to have become the sort of
intolerance almost that's crept in
the idea which is very counter to your
values as i perceive
them which is if you don't agree with
people you you debate you you express
yourself
in strong confident terms and that is
how you conduct that conversation
so what is it that's happened in this
area of of debate conversation
language everything seems to be sort of
uh you've got to be very careful you
can't offend people you can't
what's your take on that well i think
we in feeling towards common language on
this
we had a disagreement which we're about
to have again now
i don't regard these people as being on
the left if
or or if that's the left i'm not
on it uh which would make them very
happy to hear uh
there's a difference between what i call
liberalism
with a small l uh and the left or
at least there ought to be and that
ranges from the
philosophical uh through the economic
political and also on
on social values so for example i
am socially conservative in every
respect
i don't drink i hate drugs i believe in
marriage
i believe in the country i'm patriotic
i believe in the armed forces and so on
none of these are liberal
traits and they ought to be
a difference between the left
and the liberals who don't like the
family
much generally think it's old hat
although most of them live in monogamous
relationships they don't want to
theorize that
as being a good thing they would they
would attack you if you tried to
theorize that they they
seem to believe in the stupefication of
the
masses where everyone takes a drag and
drops out
which is the very antithesis of the kind
of political activism that i think is
needed in the country uh
but you're right they have become
identified as the left
they identify themselves as the left the
media identifies them as the left and
ergo the left is really unpopular
amongst the mass of the people in the
country
who don't look like them live like them
think like them talk like them
and that's a problem it means that
someone like me
has to explicitly say well if that's the
left i'm not in it
or the more difficult thing to do
to attack the idea that they are
the left now as you rightly identified
right at the beginning
the cancel culture has enveloped
not just denying someone like you
platforms
but someone like me or
on the women's front someone like my old
friend
jermaine grier she is persona non grata
she is not allowed
to appear on any university campus
although probably like me her reaction
to that has been well
stick your university campuses i would
no longer
maybe ox maybe the oxford union because
the security is good but
i wouldn't go to any other uh university
meeting and i'm invited to them all the
time at least every week
um but i wouldn't go because once
cup once canceled twice shy or in my
case
once physically attacked twice shy
um jacob rees-mogg
ran into similar difficulties
he's on the right of politics though i
agree with him on
quite a few things uh i'm on the left of
politics
and we're both effectively not welcome
in britain's universities
now that's bad for me because i don't
get the chance to
proselytize for my beliefs
amongst young people who will amongst
whom will be people who will be
journalists and politicians and opinion
makers
and foreigners in the future but it's
also bad for them
because it means that the bandwidth
of the ideas that they are being exposed
to
is incredibly narrow and
that means we get another generation
then that are inculcated with these
ideas which are coming from liberals but
are of course
entirely illiberal in any normal
definition
of the word so i believe in freedom of
speech
not just because i think the people
hearing it will be the better for it
but because if we don't have freedom of
speech even someone like me
gets cancelled and uh that's i think
where we
are in this country now i blame the
americans
[Laughter]
you may say where did all this come from
you may think
it emerged in the
in the 21st century or even in the
latter part of the 20th century but
actually i was there when it emerged
i saw it because i'm older than i look
i uh i saw it coming across the sea
from the 1968ers
their ideas throughout the 70s began
to seep across the ocean
and change the nature of left-wing
politics in
britain and i presume elsewhere though i
don't have direct
evidence of that but i presume that in
other european countries
this seepage also occurred and
i always joke about it i knew that the
british labor movement would
go into decline when our weekend schools
and summer schools we ceased to sit in
rows
and listen to leaders and began to sit
in
circles where
big tom of facebook's views were as
important as tony benz
and tony had no right to speak more than
big tom from facebook
uh i i knew that this would uh lead to
no good
and it has and george you we've talked
about the left we've talked about
you say that these people aren't on the
left but yet everybody seems to identify
them as being part of the left
do you think that the left is therefore
in crisis as a result of these people
totally uh the left as
defined and largely perceived though
we're trying to
change that uh is
in the existential crisis of being
regarded by
the people it hopes to lead as alien
as foreign as repulsive
actually so
i don't know that you can do it entirely
geographically because there are many
parts of
london even never mind the south that
are in that bag
but the father generally speaking the
farther north you go in the country
the more alien these people seem
and it seems to me a cinequanon of
seeking to
lead people seeking to get their votes
obtain their trust and then lead them in
a certain direction
it's quite important that they are that
you are not seen by them
as someone who hates them who hates
their country
hates its history hates its culture
uh because well at the very least
they're not going to vote you for you
if they think that's what you think of
them
and worst it produces
a recoil a backlash
in which other populists
from the far right can win an audience
and
attraction amongst the people that have
been repelled
by you so crisis absolute crisis
and do you therefore think that if you
look at the labour party as it is now
where you've got these activists on one
side you've got kierstarma on another
don't you look at the labour party and
think this isn't viable
long term as a political party you can't
you simply can't hold
these two types of people and everybody
else within one political
and then throw a blue labor into the mix
as well yeah i i i thought that for a
very long time
um and electorally that is proving to be
the
case my problem is i'm not with either
i'm not with starman and i'm not with
corbin
uh i'm i'm not with the
the ragged unwashed
successor generations to the 1968ers
neither am i with the centrists i was
thinking over
because this is the death anniversary of
jay guevara
i was thinking over the centrists have
no heroes
i pity that i pity them for that who's
your hero
armor a block of wood
so wooden the birds are trying to nest
in them
or is a guy that looks like acts like
lives like
he's just emerged from a student squat
and that is the dichotomy that
that the traditional left now
possesses or is in the grip of and
for someone like me who's not with
either of these trends
it's uh it's a lonely furrow
um it's not lonely in that a lot of
people agree with me but
it's lonely in the sense that in an
organized way
most of what is thought of as the left
is alien to me
that's not where i expected to find out
find myself when i started out in the
1960s
well one of the things this obviously
creates in terms of certainly british
politics
is that we've we've had a conservative
government for 10 years
i've been very in terms of voting i've
been very politically
promiscuous in my life i've voted
everything from lib dem to for you when
i was living in this area to
voting for the conservatives for the
first time in my life at the last
election
and you look at the conservatives now
you have to say that they're completely
useless
but you don't see them being credibly
challenged at the next election even now
because we don't have a credible
opposition where does that leave the
country
uh up the creek without a paddle
we we have not faced
a potentially existential crisis like
this
since the summer of 1940 when hitler was
at the channel ports
when the soviet union hadn't entered the
war
and where any day the
fascist hordes could have landed on the
southern
coast we really have not faced a crisis
like this
not just the public health crisis but
the economic crisis which
accompanies it and we have a government
that
is to continue the watery metaphor lost
at sea
and we have an opposition which is
probably not even a scintilla better
than the
than the government that's lost at sea
and that is a very difficult
place to find yourself in 1940
churchill stepped forward the
ineffectual
inept throwback
to a previous century of the chamberlain
clique
was overthrown and and the rest is
history
but there's no churchill in this picture
there's no churchill in the house of
commons there's not even an athlete
in the in the house of commons there's
nothing that you could say
we could get behind this part this
person these people
this this plan not all
on the country i think we're heading
again to continue the watery
metaphor into very turbulent times
indeed
turbulent waters and you've just
mentioned that we don't have a church we
don't even have an
athlete in fact we were talking with
peter hitchins and he was saying there
was no big beasts of politics left
anymore
why do you think that is george why do
you think that we don't have even
thatcher who you would probably ardently
will not probably disagree with
you can't deny that she was a force of
nature
and not only was she uh there was a
hundred or 150 such
big beasts when i entered parliament
just over 30 years ago 33
years ago you could look around and your
mouth would open
that's michael eiselton going past
that's tony ben that's dennis healy
peter shaw and so on
and that's not ancient history it's only
1987.
so thatchar of course was a big beast a
formidable
figure and now there are no thatchers no
bends no shores
uh so what's happened
i put it down to the the the death of
ideology
the uh belief in an alternative society
died with the with the soviet collapse
uh not that the left in britain
was pro-soviet but the existence of the
soviet union
at least implied that there was another
way that you could run things
that died the left
the labour movement completely lost
confidence
lost hope uh turned to the eu
turned to jacques de laure from from
lenin to jacques delores a long way
they uh they sought uh a
a kind of corporatist uh protection
uh from the from the eu uh
and the with the the the death of
thatcher is well thatcherism not really
dead but
with the passing from power of mrs
thatcher and her replacement
by a desiccated calculating machine
called john major but one whose
batteries were running out
the the whole thing went downhill from
there labor's conclusion
was that they needed to find
a tailor's dummy that could talk
and they came up with tony blair i was
there
i was on john prescott's leadership team
that's how bad the choice was
and tony blair romped
home and uh with predictable
results so labour marched across the
political terrain
uh and the tories followed them uh the
the tories are blairites really uh
so thatcherism has very much been
succeeded
by blarism the labour brand and the
toray
uh brand what was david cameron if not
a kind of tony blair without the laughs
uh he was ersatz blair
um and uh i'm
i had some hope that uh that boris
johnson would
would prove uh different he hasn't
really
i mean boris johnson despite all the
epithets that are hurled at him he's
actually quite a liberal figure
with liberal ideas on on the economy in
society and he certainly lived the high
liberal life he's a party man
not that kind of party right but but
hasn't proven to be competent
which look i maybe if we didn't have a
global pandemic and a massive economic
crisis to deal with
he would have been the sort of
cheerleader that sort of saw the country
through brexit
and minor obstacles in its path but
it's the time as you say for churchills
and thatchers and we don't have any
at the moment which i think should worry
everybody
when we started this show two and a half
years ago
we had one dream and that dream is now
fulfilled
finally after all the hard work we're
advertising b days
and it's not just any b days it's skoosh
bing days
and not just scooch b days these are b
day
attachments which means that if you
don't have the space
in your toilet for a beading maybe
because you're an ordinary
you can get an attachment and it's dirt
cheap
no pun intended and it's far more
hygienic for you to clean yourself with
it's that easy to install it's
environmentally friendly
and finally since we're running out of
paper it's the perfect solution
absolutely so if you want the
hygienic and save the planet as well
alternative to toilet paper
go to dot shop that's skoosh
dot shop for all your b day needs
excuse b day are offering all
trigonometry fans a 10
discount just head over to their website
and enter
our code which is t p o d one
to get your amazing discount that's t p
o
d one to get ten percent off a beda
so glad we finally achieved our dreams
but we do have some real problems ahead
don't we george
uh i don't know what your take is on the
on on the response to the pandemic
actually let's talk about that briefly
what do you make of how we're dealing
with it now
being half an irishman i'm entitled to
say
as the apocryphal irishman asked the
road and distance to dublin
i wouldn't have started from here
so we're in a big mess now because we
didn't start
where we ought to have started uh
i was opining just yesterday it's proved
uh
quite a successful tweet that there are
more uh coronavirus cases in the white
house than there are
in new zealand taiwan
and south korea put together there's
china and south korea and vietnam
and new zealand disparate social
political systems there's virtually no
coronavirus it's been vanquished
and yet we are in a state of panic
the united states still more so alone
marginally more so
considering the difference in the size
of the countries
and that's because we didn't do what
south korea did
at the very beginning which was to
absolutely go to war uh
immediately mobilize their population
their public health system
and their economy uh to to fight this
thing
and they have done it so successfully
that you can
get a test for the coronavirus at the
bus stop
literally on the bus stop i don't know
if you blow into it or suck it or what
you do but it's there
on the bus stop i at 66.
could not get for love nor money
a test about four weeks ago when i had a
cough
and thought i probably better get a test
i could not get one i couldn't get
through on the website
i couldn't get through on the emergency
number i couldn't find anybody
even that would take my money to give me
one
that's how far away from south korea we
are
uh on this new zealand of course a bit
of a special case because of the
sparsity of the
population and so on although scotland
is comparable to
new zealand in many such respects
and scotland is worse than england
glasgow is the worst
place in the country so we've gone about
this
entirely the wrong way and that's partly
a consequence
of the rundown in the public health
system
over the last 20 or more years
but it's also about this failure of
leadership
we we live in a country as many other
countries
nobody believes the leaders even when
they're telling the truth
and nobody gets there's no mobilization
there's no sense of us and always
that we are a people a country a state
with
leaders warts and all we must follow
them
there's no sense of that in britain so
we had a substantial number
a weird left right crossover
of deniers that
stretch from libertarians who'd rather
die than wear a mask
to left-wing idiots who
thought it was all a conspiracy
by bill gates the hapless bill gates
who became the new rothschild you just
had to say his name
and nod and wink that weird crossover
existed and it was noisy on social media
but if we'd had a strong leadership and
a strong state
then we would have been able to rally
everyone behind us and we would have
been able to count on people
see it would be far better if you could
count on 65 million people to do the
right thing
you wouldn't need fines you wouldn't
need you
you didn't have to find people in the
second world war
in the east end of london to make sure
they had blackout
uh in their windows and that they
weren't uh
showing light to the bombers coming not
not a mile from here
this place was all on fire completely on
fire so
there was no need because the people
believed
in the country's leadership they
believed in the concept of our country
and us we have lost that
so where we go from here
i've really got no idea nothing that
they are doing
is working they're throwing money around
like uh like the magic
money tree was in every street
and saw figures the other day on uh
testing tracking and tracing ireland
has spent 733 000 pounds
and we have spent 12 billion
billion pounds and where is it where's
the tests where's the tracking where's
the tracing
this has been either a gigantic
organized scam to make
a few people exceedingly rich or it is
the most
incompetent [ __ ] show ever seen
in these islands uh because how you
managed to spend
12 billion pounds on a system that is
practically invisible
it's very difficult to compute and yet
it goes back to constantine's point as
well that
you look over at the opposition and they
don't seem to have any
ideas either no in fact when kierstalmer
is asked what he'd do
pretty much do the same as boris cart
blanche he's given them
carte blanche and then what as boris
points out quite effectively actually
what were you complaining about you
supported it last week
you gave us your full support on this
two weeks ago i saw him yesterday
or in the house uh wednesday uh he said
but but this complaint you're making is
about the very thing you supported not
two weeks ago
uh so for me starmar
is worse in the sense that
uh you've got the opportunity as an
opposition
because you don't have responsibility to
explore different
uh different ways in all directions by
the way
uh i'm ready to listen to an argument
that says
now that we are where we are we might as
well stop
uh trying to fight it we might as well
face it uh because the situation is so
bad
i'm ready to hear that argument and an
opposition is in a position to
explore these things but stammer seems
to me like a guy who's strapped himself
into a straight jacket and is
uh merely going through the motions
of opposition and i see he's sliding
again
in the in the polls boris despite
everything
has risen in the latest ball by two
points um
but i think the feeling in the country
is
by god both of these are jokers
uh neither of these you wouldn't as we
say in glasgow you wouldn't send them
out
for a loaf you wouldn't ask them to go
to the shop for a loaf of bread
and have any real confidence that they
come back with the right bread
the right change or even the bread and
you said that we don't have this idea of
a country this idea
of you know as a big society do you
think the roots of that lie in
thatcherism that famous quote from
margaret thatcher there's no such thing
as society
well she crystallized it with that
address to of all places the church of
scotland the most
twee presbyterian assembly anywhere on
these islands she
effectively attacked uh central tenet of
christianity there she had balls
she um she crystallized it but i don't
think it begins
with uh with her i i think that
after the second world war britain felt
and was
depleted and there was the the long
period uh of uh
after a short period of uh post-war
reconstruction
there was a long period of what we
called butt scalism
which was rob butler and hugh gateskill
two sides of the same coin
where nobody really argued much about
the central
tenets of how society should be
organized
even though it was increasingly liberal
through the 60s nobody really argued it
wasn't until thatcher came along
that there was any sharp rupture
ideologically in britain but undoubtedly
if you privatize everything
if you exalt individualism
over collectivism if public becomes bad
private becomes good
uh if that dichotomy sets in then you're
you're going to be in less good shape to
face it
so take a look at these places i
mentioned that have done well
uh south korea never mind north korea
right south korea is a capitalist
uh country an american ally
but it is an extremely cohesive place
it's a place that marches as one uh when
necessary it's a place that moves as one
uh and of course china is very much
the ultimate expression of that in the
world today
and they went i mean they fought the
coronavirus
like it was world war iii
and now they're living totally normal
lives
even in wuhan and we are
scared to go out the door our
businesses are shutting down scotland
this evening at six o'clock will become
a ghost town and i'm told that
boris is planning the same thing here
in england um even alcohol's been banned
in scotland that's not going to end well
isn't it that cannot end well
um so we we're we are
this is a dog's breakfast and i don't
have the resources to know
exactly where we are and what we should
now do
but i'm ready to listen to offers i'm
ready to listen to
any idea from credible people
about where we go from now and it may be
that that'll be a very different way
from the way i advocated strongly at the
beginning
do you have a business do you want to
make the most of your business
do you want to advertise online but
don't know where to do it
well how about you advertise with
trigonometry we have
over 200 000 subscribers across the
different platforms
we sometimes get up to 3 million views a
month for our videos
and it's a great opportunity to showcase
your product so if you want your product
or business to stand out
amidst all the nonsense that is
happening drop
us a line at marketing trigger pod
co dot that's marketing at trigger pod
dot co dot uk and we will do our very
best
to help your product stand out and when
we say stand out what we really mean is
get cancelled well
i mean one of the arguments we've heard
on our show from doctors
like dr carol sakura for example is
actually that
the average age of death for someone
with covet in this country is 82
average life expectancy is 82 and a half
so the people who are dying are mostly
people who
were were either very ill or very old
uh and what you do is you protect those
people and let everybody else
get on with their lives and then you
don't ruin the economy i mean that's one
of the
options that maybe kierstama should
explore as someone who's an opposition
has more leeway
yes uh of course those numbers
i don't know how long ago you spoke to
them uh are coming down
the big spike now is amongst young
people
uh we don't but that's cases that's not
deaths right yeah it's coming from yeah
we don't yet know where those cases will
go uh
if they pass uh with a couple of weeks
of misery for
the thousands of students who appear to
be infected
uh by the way bringing students back to
university was a major league disaster
and whoever is responsible for that
really should be up against the wall and
shot it's the old pro-soviet
with each other quite well without being
in the same room
yeah uh the uh this has led to
i mean in the university of northumbria
they did a mass test 775 people tested
positive
in the university of glasgow again many
hundreds
uh leading to a situation where students
have gone to university and are now
locked
in what is effectively a cell
and not allowed to go out and no point
now because
even the alcohol is banned at six
o'clock for everybody never mind you
uh and so on so um the numbers of
k the numbers of uh cases has
dramatically spiked
amongst young people and we don't yet
know the time of recording
uh quite how serious they will be
neither do we know what level of
immunity and for how long
having caught it will provide you i'm
waiting for my
my sputnik v uh sputnik 5
vaccine which i've requested from the
kremlin
but they seem to be a bit slow in
getting it to me maybe they
there's a bit in your cup of tea than i
said earlier maybe they're worried that
it might not work and they'll lose a
major asset but
the the uh the the vaccine
process here seems extremely slow
uh cuba has a vaccine china has one
russia has one
will not buy them for ideological
reasons
so there is a still a case
for quarantining
certain sections of the most vulnerable
people
but it's not foolproof that constantine
because
you can lock up your granny but you
can't lock her up forever
and one grandchild is
going to get through and nobody wants to
lose their granny even if they are 82.
of course so i'm not with the
if you like with the libertarians uh on
that
but i'm ready for fresh ideas
but they're few and far between yeah it
does appear that we're hitting crisis
point we're not
hitting we've hit crisis point with a
pandemic the thing that i really wanted
to talk to you about george
is uh socialism because it seems
that it's we're seeing a bit of a
resurgent in people who identify as
socialism
we've seen it in america with
politicians like aoc
what does socialism mean to you for a
start and then we'll go on and discuss
it further
yeah i'm glad you brought that up
because i started
out by explaining what i think is a
dichotomy between liberalism
and and socialism and i'm not a liberal
but i am a socialist
um i think it's partly because
capitalism isn't working to paraphrase
mrs thatcher if you were to do a poster
today like hers
when she said socialism wasn't working
it would be a much longer queue
there's far more people now unemployed
under uh under the capitalist system
than there
possibly has ever been the american
unemployment rate is now
as high as it was in the 1930s in the
great depression
there's a wave of evictions on top of
that because
banks are foreclosing on landlords
landlords can't get the rent
out the people and result misery
if the united states economy doesn't
pick up
i don't believe it will then we will
very shortly
in this winter have greater levels of
unemployment in the us
than we did in the great depression our
bounce back
uh seems to have stalled um our
growth rate for august was was 2.1
percent
despite the most gigantic
handout from the state that there has
ever been in
eat out to help out
which may have spread the virus and may
have stalled the
recovery help to stall the recovery um
so it's quite likely that by this winter
our
levels of unemployment will be over 10
uh if you think well you're too young to
know but
when you be 40 clue being in the name
uh we're talking about the one in 10
and they were talking about the one in
10 unemployed
people thought it was something else but
that's what it was and they're friends
of mine
so it's quite likely that this winter
we'll be
right back in the in the depths
of depression and therefore
the famous thatcher queue is now much
bigger so capitalism
isn't working and therefore people are
looking for
an alternative and the only
feasible alternative for me uh
in developed societies
with huge populations which like ours
65 million is a big population on a
piece of land this size
is to organize ourselves in a wholly
different way with the state
playing a decisive role in the
organization of society and the economy
by which i don't mean the
nationalization of
everything or even necessarily anything
i mean the state with a decisive
directing role in what happens so
i'm not in favor as i always put it
anyone that's
ever seen a bulgarian communist party
official's
suit knows that they're not good at
tailoring
anyone who's ever been in an eastern
european
soviet-era restaurant knows that they're
not good at restaurants
there are some things that are too
specialist too small
two need to be too flexible to be
organized by the state
uh art culture and so on among them
but there are some things that are too
important to be left to a private sector
that is manifestly
failing so i believe
i i've not only been in china a couple
of times
i don't know it well but i would say
that the
chinese model of synthesizing
private enterprise free enterprise
capitalism
with a strong central role for the state
it's not a surprise to me that the
chinese economy is the most successful
economy
in the world that it will very shortly
be the biggest
it's been the most transformative in the
numbers of people that it has lifted out
of poverty
in fact it's lifted the greatest number
of people out of poverty of any system
any country ever
in history and it is now
i've seen i did a piece yesterday about
the demands of the international
financial community
for china to be more easy on its debtors
that's how far they've come that the
world bank
is asking china to forgive debts and
reschedule debts for the poor countries
that they have lent money to
that's how rich and powerful and
successful
china now is so i would uh
if i was designing the economy that is
roughly the kind of economy that i would
favor it wouldn't be communism
i'm not a communist it wouldn't be
the soviet union which was a failure
it would be something new and i think
the chinese synthesis
is if i can borrow a phrase from tony
blair is the third way
it's interesting i mean you talk about
the statistics of unemployment the
economy failing obviously
prior to coronavirus the economy in the
united states was
ostensibly doing well here the same but
nonetheless
i think the rise of that sort of
thinking actually predates the
coronavirus the unemployment that we're
seeing and i'm going to see and when we
talk about capitalism not working i
would say certainly people of our
generation and below
it's not so much about the unemployment
that the results from kovit that caused
that but perhaps
the situation with housing in this
country which for young people is
absolutely atrocious uh and also the
feeling that perhaps for the first time
in living memory uh the chil your
children will do worse than you are
doing than you did uh that their living
standards will be lower that their
access
to good jobs despite half of them now
attempting to go to university and
racking up massive debts despite all of
that
their life outcomes are going to be
worse so i would argue that
and i'm not a fan of socialism by the
but i would argue the reason that people
are drawn to it
is that we've had these systemic
problems that predate the current crisis
in
in a very big way would you agree with
that yeah and i don't agree that the
uh u.s and british economies were doing
well before the virus
as a matter of fact the uh the
recession began before the virus
uh a month or two before the virus but
it had been coming
effectively we slump every seven
eight years and therefore this slump
uh would have happened anyway was
overdue
and had begun before the virus but the
virus has proved
that our vitals are not capable of
withstanding
shocks like slump like recession
like viruses all of which by the way
were entirely predictable and predicted
that this government the conservative
government did
uh how would you call it an exercise
uh some three years ago i forget what it
was called now
in which the which was predicated on a
coronavirus
and quickly had to cover up
the exercise because the model
basically collapsed under the weight so
if you
live in a society that cannot with that
regularly slumps
that cannot withstand any existential
joke then that society is not fit for
purpose needs to be
changed the reason why we have a housing
crisis is because of capitalism
again sorry to play the age card but i
was there
i opposed mrs thatcher's drive
to sell off council houses because i
knew it would lead to
what it has led and i was one i was the
labour party leader in dundee we were
one of only two or three
two places in the country that refused
to sell council houses
the government sent in the bailiffs and
a high court judge
who was later found
to be up to unfortunate things in a
public lavatory somewhere
[Laughter]
we hated him not for that reason but
because he'd been sent
in by mrs thatcher to sell our houses
what we need in britain is a mass
construction should be an economic
multiplier for a star
of good quality affordable council
housing
council housing is the best form of
housing because you elect your landlord
your landlord cannot afford to ignore
you uh
in a way that a private landlord can uh
your your your landlord has to listen
uh because you've got a vote and you can
vote them out or you can vote their boss
out
uh in the local authority a mass
a mass drive of millions of council
houses
would transform the situation in britain
um i'm not saying because i grew up in
one
uh that the the the council house estate
of the 1960s
is the acme it isn't uh
i always favor titoism over stalinism
uh and uh yugoslavia had
many more innovative ways of practicing
socialism uh and i like that
um so capitalism isn't working
for young people 50 of our people are
going to university
but a very small number of them end up
doing anything
commensurate with the investment that's
been made in their education
we are when i was the mp for this very
street
the london olympics stadium was being
built
i stormed in to the minister
the late tessa joel demanding to know
why none of my constituents
could get jobs on the site why everybody
that was building it
was from poland or bulgaria
and she halted me in my tracks
by saying that there are no
tradesmen unemployed in your
constituency
they're just not many tradesmen in your
constituency and that's why
we're having to employ them from poland
this is madness
we've got thousands of unemployed
journalism graduates
but we can't build our own olympic
stadium because
we don't have enough joiners glaziers
electricians
plumbers that's not a functioning
society a properly functioning
society so on all levels unemployment
increasing poverty food insecurity
the housing crisis capitalism isn't
working so
to go back to your question why would
socialism
not be something that people were now
looking at
of course socialism had many failures i
don't need to tell you that
or him his mother's from venezuela okay
socialism has many failures but so does
capitalism
and therefore we need to find a better
way
and i think that people are increasingly
searching for that better way they just
won't find it in kierstarm
or jeremy corbyn for that matter and
what do you think about the growing
inequality between rich and poor because
it
seems that the gap is now bigger than
ever uh constantine and i were in
trafalgar square
about a month ago and we were shocked to
see
hundreds of people lining up on
trafalgar square for a food bank
and these were traditionally people that
you wouldn't think would have to queue
up to get food handed to them
well yesterday i was shooting a film i
wasn't in it but
directing it in hyde park uh
the site of the great exhibition uh
it was about charles dickens i can't
tell you much more than that but
the gap between rich and poor in britain
today is wider than it was when
charles dickens was writing oliver twist
and that's a hundred and
forty years ago so if in 140 years
you've gone backwards in terms of
equality
then you're not doing it right and what
you
just described and that's in the heart
of london in the heart of the empire
i could take you places in the north of
england
and in some parts of scotland where
life expectancy itself is going
backwards
where people will not just live lives
less good than their parents
but they'll live less long than their
parents
that's a crisis and it's one that
nobody is yet addressing but which the
discerning
can see is a fundamental crisis
so and we haven't yet as ronald reagan
would say we ain't seen nothing yet
uh if that's trafalgar square in
the autumn of 2020 wait to february 2021
there could be serious problems could be
a disruption to social peace
in this country because of mass
unemployment
and poverty and it's a very important
point the inequality because we have a
lot of guests on the show from all over
the political spectrum people on the
right people on the left
i sort of think of myself somewhere in
the center but it doesn't matter where
you are in the spectrum
the objective fact is and the evidence
shows this very clearly
the more inequality there is in the
western democracy the worse that is for
everybody including the rich people of
course
even for billionaires it's worse um so
that's how many gates can you put on
your community
exactly and how effective can this if
you live in a crime-ridden society
where people don't have any food like
you say it doesn't matter how many
gates or doors or whatever you're not
going to have a good life
and that's something that we're just
we're going to have to address and and
finding some
some way of doing that is going to be
essential but george we wanted to
talk to you about one other thing can i
just ask one question
before we do which is how much blame
does globalization have to take for this
uh a very great deal uh globalization is
a deeply flawed idea
uh and it's at the heart of this
crisis we we can't get ppe why because
it comes
10 000 miles from china why
why can't we make masks rubber gloves
this was the workshop of the world
[Music]
at the time of the great exhibition
and dickens that i was filming yesterday
this was the workshop of the world we
sailed the seven
seas in ships of steel
laden with our manufacturers and now we
can't make rubber gloves
we've got to buy them from 10 000 miles
away
this is a cataclysmic failure
and the british capitalist class has to
take a share of the responsibility for
that
but the decline of
national control and direction
it's not just an economic problem it's a
socio-political one
it's the reason why we voted for brexit
because we correctly identified that we
were no longer in control
of anything meaningful in our lives not
just we weren't
but our government wasn't our state
wasn't
and that meant that not just the supply
lines were too long but the political
command lines
were too long and we couldn't affect
them
and so globalization is hated by people
they don't put it that way most people
most people probably never utter the
word globalization
but they know it's like the camel
difficult to define
easy to recognize uh the
the the people know that far too much
of what we buy and consume and eat
is coming from somewhere else and the
things that we used to do
ourselves are now done by someone else
and for the profit of a few
i mean u.s capital didn't relocate to
china because they love
chop suey they relocated to china
because
they could make more money manufacturing
in china leading to
the closure of the rust belt
and we've got our own rust belt here in
britain
roughly co-terminus with the with the
red wall
which is why brexit happens why i knew
it would happen
why i advocated that it should happen
and why i was entirely unsurprised when
it happened
unlike the liberal elite of
people who benefit from globalization
here
if you live beside me i'm in the process
of moving to scotland
less true there but in my part of london
why would you not be in favor of the eu
why would you not be in favor of
globalization
you're luxuriating not just benefiting
from it
you're luxuriating in it but of course
the farther away from that bubble you go
the less attractive the consequences of
globalization
are you don't have money for a
for a macchiato and so it doesn't matter
that
an attractive barista from slovenia
is serving it to you and historically
low price because you don't even know
what macchiato is
you don't go to you don't have a barista
you don't have an au pair
you don't have the money to pay for a
polish electrician
to build your basement or your your
extension and so on and that's the tale
to
continue the dickens point that's the
tale of two cities
that we are living in within one country
globalization is to blame it's an issue
we've talked a lot about on the show and
brexit is something we've explored
um even though we both like to remain
because
we're good people
that always used to be the thing we used
to do for a joke
but we've had many pro-brexit guests on
to to explore that very point and it's
it's undeniable george it's been a great
interview but there's one other thing
that we before we get to our final
question itself
that we really wanted to talk to you
about that we don't really see disgust
anymore and i actually think it is a
very important point which is julian
assange
for for anyone who doesn't know anything
about it whatsoever
you're a man with very clear thinking
who understands that particular
situation very well so just
explain to someone who doesn't know
anything at all what is that all about
and why is
he in the position that he's in now well
full disclosure julian
assange is a personal friend of mine uh
and when i could no longer go into the
embassy to see him i stood outside
and sang frank sinatra's songs to him
through the window
i'm actually not a bad singer and julian
likes frank sinatra
julian assange is
a world historic figure
whatever happens in this court case he
has developed an entirely new model of
journalism
one which facilitates the
exposure of material and information
that the powerful don't want to see
disclosed and
that is the very definition of
journalism
if nobody doesn't want you to say what
you're saying
and doing then what you're saying and
doing probably isn't worth
a raw beans because if it's not
hurting someone somewhere amongst the
powerful
what you are revealing then is probably
not worth revealing
and so julian in during the time that
i have been his friend has revealed some
of the most
sensational material
ever only some of which he's on trial
for
he's essentially on trial now for
revealing
war crimes committed by the united
states and
others in the invasion and occupation of
iraq and afghanistan which
when i started out opposing it was a
deeply unpopular stance
mine i could show you mascaras
but you can now now not find a sentient
being in the land
who any longer thinks that invading and
occupying iraq was a good idea
but julian during that period
when things were different
revealed big crimes
systemic crimes uh in the war logs
which showed mass killing of civilians
of journalists a totally cavalier
attitude to wiping people out whether
they were
men women or children whether they were
reuters reporters
whether they were prisoners being
forced to commit indecent acts upon each
other in the abu ghraib prison
and be photographed for the
entertainment
of the torturers afterwards and
videotaped and so
on julian broke all these stories he
also broke a lot of stories
this is why i'm a bit surprised that
donald trump is pursuing him with the
gusto
that he is i still live by the way in
hope
that donald trump will pardon him he
also revealed
although he's not on trial for this the
absolute
venality of the clinton crime gang
and the so-called democratic party in
the united states of
america and sure that benefited trump
but it benefited all of us to know that
hillary clinton was a crook and that the
clinton crime family were up to the neck
in all kinds of vice
venality and corruption we all needed to
know that
not least because they were secular
saints
in western society julian revealed
many stories which cast these people
in a new light for which he now faces
175 years in a super max prison
in the united states so this story is
important and yet entirely ignored
by the very liberal class of journalists
and broadcasters that
feasted on the dripping roast of his
revelations
and so if you were going to ask me who
do i hate most
in the whole world i tell you the
guardian
the guardian newspaper personifies
everything that i hate in society and
one of the reasons
is the guardian feasted on julian's
stories
ran them over and over again on the
front page
of their newspaper and have remained
utterly silent while he's persecuted
prosecuted and banished forever into the
bowels
of a super max prison even though
that very process may one day be used
against them and could be i mean if
julian has committed an offense
in publishing these stories so have they
in publishing these stories
their editor could now be on trial maybe
one day
will be and if we get to a situation
where our country it's america today
it could be saudi arabia tomorrow
saudi arabia could for example
i was a good friend of adnan khashoggi
who was
murdered by the saudi uh
dictatorship and literally cut into
pieces and flushed into a drain
but when he was living here in london
and in fact he was living in washington
when that happened to him
the saudis could have sought his
extradition to
saudi arabia now you might say it's
fanciful that any british court would
send someone to saudi arabia
it's not that fanciful if you could send
someone to 175 years
in a super max in america if the saudis
had said we won't cut his head off
we'll only put them in prison for 175
years
they could have extradited adnan
khashoggi
might have been better than the end that
he had
but it could happen to anybody it could
happen to you could happen to you
you're seditious
here seditious to somebody
you know that would make a lot of people
very happy to us so it could well
lead to some foreign power
extraditing you and destroying you
now when this unequal extradition treaty
was concluded in secret
in summer when the house was not sitting
by david blanket tony blair's home
secretary
you may say i am a soothsayer
i personally raised with david blanket
emotional because i didn't know julian
at that time
a notional case whereby
a journalist whistleblower could be
extradited
without just cause being needed to be
shown could be extradited to the united
states
under this extradition treaty
david blanket gave me a personal
assurance
that it was on the face of the bill that
no one could be
extradited for a political crime
in his secret extradition treaty that
was signed before we even knew it
existed
how's that for parliamentary democracy i
was an mp at the time
for here actually uh this very street
and he said to me he showed me the
declaration on the face of the bill on
the face of the treaty
that this could not happen my fear could
never
come to pass but it has come to pass
and the get out
is well he's not being extradited for a
political crime it's being extradited
for
effectively espionage even though he's
not a citizen of the united states
and never set foot there never committed
any crime there
um and so the promises sick transit
gloria
david blanket where is he now what are
wha
what were his promises worth they were
not worth the paper that they were
written on
and so if you believe in freedom of
speech if you believe in journalism
if you believe in the right of the
public to know
uh what is being done in their name on
their dollar
you need to be concerned about what's
happening to julian assange and lastly
you call me old-fashioned i believed
still to some extent believe that the
last
uncorrupted institution in great britain
was the judiciary i know the social
caste from which they come
i know they're not elected and cannot be
removed
but when i look at how all our
institutions have failed one after the
other
the civil service the media
even the police they've all failed us
one after the other
i thought the one that was left was the
judiciary i always used to say
and my father before me actually long
before these institutions uh
failed i'd rather take my chances in
front of a british judge
than in front of a british politician or
a british journalist
or any of a british police officer and
so on
and therefore the abuse of process
on view openly
if you care enough to look at it in this
case
has been so gargantuan i'll give you
just one example
because time is running
if i told you that you could be
extradited even though
it is established fact that
all of your meetings with your lawyers
were filmed by the prosecuting authority
in the united states of their agents so
they know
all of what your defense is i speak as
one who was secretly filmed
in the embassy having a
pee talk everything i said was filmed
i can live with that but julian's
lawyers
were secretly filmed talking to him
preparing
him and he preparing them
for his defense in a court case that
might one day have to take place in
london
you would say such a case would have to
be thrown out
even if it was a traffic offense it
would have to be thrown out
if the police were filming you and your
discussions with your lawyers
but that happened nobody disputes that
it happened
all the evidence has been
laid in front of this court in london at
the old bailey
the old lady of british justice but it
will not make a blind bit
of difference the fact that such an
abusive process
that could give you 500 other abuses of
process that have happened
has not made any impact on this case
means that we have to fear
for the justice system in our own
country
itself and we not you
me someone wholly british
were led to believe and did believe that
british justice was really
something that it was justice that that
statue at top of the old building
of uh of uh the lady with the scales
really was something turns out it wasn't
turns out it seems unless
in the appeal process this is overturned
that julian is going to be sent to 175
years in prison
for the crime of telling the truth
that's a terrible story and one of the
things that i always think about is
we really should be incentivizing people
to to whistle blow
to reveal these things that should be
something that's encouraged you should
be celebrated paid money
whatever it is should be it's a vital
part of any democratic process
and yet here we are allowing this man to
be extradited to another country to face
injustice not justice but injustice
i'm glad we got a chance to talk to you
about that me too you do it's an issue
that
you don't see covered and frankly very
few people know about really
uh but george with that in mind we've
got one more question for you which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about
but we really should be that's a
curveball
uh how manchester united managed to
spend
1 billion pounds and produce what we
produced against tottenham hotspur
last weekend that's something that's
occupying quite a few of my brain cells
one billion uh to assemble a squad of
misfits
misfiring uh
disasters uh is uh is something football
is a national religion in
britain uh we're quite good at it we
invented it
manchester united has been my team since
1965.
i've never been more miserable about
that i feel guilty that my children are
decked out
manchester united here and
my six-year-old son who's a protege
remember his name
tauren galloway you'll still be around
when
he's a top player uh he turned to me and
said how
could manchester united lose 6-1 to
tottenham hotspur or to anybody
uh so that is uh that is something that
we should be talking about but it may be
off your beating track did you want a
more serious no that's fine but i've
always said this as a west ham fan i
think it's something that should be
celebrated
david moyes that's all i'm going to say
yeah tauren galway will be playing
upfront for everton when we win the
league well i'd be
i i'd be honored if he uh if he was ma
there was a
there was an iconic player called jimmy
gabriel
uh who came from dundee my town to
everton
and became in the 1960s
an iconic everton a player so i was
brought up
always to look for the everton score
i've got soft spot
for the everton but i never thought
they'd ever assemble a team
like they appear to have assembled now
they are dark horses
for the league this year remember you
heard it and you at home watching you
cannot see anton's face but i've never
seen them
seen him this happy george thank you so
much for coming on it's been a real
pleasure uh i hope the viewers think so
i mean to speak for so long
uh and not be bored for a second uh
is i think an achievement so thanks
thank you and the people want to hear
you speak for a lot longer
they can tune in of course to the mother
or talk shows which is normally on
sundays
still on sundays it's free to air every
sunday
and you can watch on twitter on
instagram
facebook youtube multiple platforms even
something called twitch
for gaming yeah uh and
a million people a week are now watching
it well in fact a million people are
watching it on the night
close to a million and a half over the
course of a week
but we've started a midweek mother of
all talk shows
which only cost one dollar seventy pence
and that's george galloway bare knuckle
so if you know what i'm like on a sunday
night
imagine what i'm like bare knuckle so i
hope people can do it on patreon
and on facebook make sure you go and
find that and of course follow george
on twitter as well thank you so much for
watching we'll see you
very soon absolutely guys for a live
stream
which goes out on tuesday thursday
friday and saturday at 7 pm uk time
and our episodes which go out on
wednesday and sunday again
at 7 p.m uk time take care and see you
soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word